هذا يعني انه الدائره التي
مناط بها او ستتولى اختيار خليفه للمرشد
ليست مستقله على
الاطلاقيه باتت ضعيفه جدا خلال قياده الله
خامنئي وهذه بالمناسبه هي من الاسباب
الرئيسيه ضعف المؤسسات المدنيه هي من
الاسباب التي تشهد فيها الانقراض العسكريه
حول العالم هذه من القواسم المشتركه بين
الدول التي تعيش انقلابات عسكريه السبب
الاخر وهو ايضا قاسم مشترك بين الدول التي
تشهد انقلابات هو ان القياده المدنيه
تستغل الجيش
المشاركه الاعمال السياسيه وحاله ما نرجع
اصحاب السلاح تدخل في سياسات
بعد من الاستحاله التخلص منهم مره اخرى
انا بانه باي حال من الاحوال انه ممكن في
شخصيه عسكريه او قوميه يمكن ان تظهر في
ايران
ظهور
القوميه بنصف الحرس الثوري همم احتمال
ربما ورد سبقه وان شاهدنا قاسم سليمان
ماني همم الذي استمتعه ببعض الشهرا او
الشعبيه ليس فقط من الدعم لان النظام
الايرانيين بشكل عام ايضا وربما نشهد
بروزان شخصيه كارزماتيه اخرى من صفوف
الحرس الثوري ولكن
اعتقد بانهم من ارجع انا الحارس الفوري
سيحاول ان يكون هنالك خليفه
ويحتفظ
النظام من اجل تقليدي التكلفه التغيرات
السياسيه وبالمناسبه ومن اجل
والجغراف كل شيء ايضا او اخطاء كثيره
استفسار في ايران في المفضل لحرس الثوري
ان يكون هنالك قائد مدني تحمل مسؤوليتي كل
الاخطاء الحاصله وبعد ذلك ياتي لحرس
الثوري ليفخرا
بالانتصارات التي سيحققها بمعنى انه شكل
الجمهوريه لن يتغير كثيرا بعد وفاه المرشد
صحيح
هو
الخلافه على امنا ايوه وبروزي القائد او
رجل الدين وهو قائد فقط بالاسم ولكنها تاب
اللي حرس الثوري السيناريو الاخر وهو
الاستيلاء المباشر على
الدوري
بان الحكم غير مباشره هو الاسلوب المفضل
لي الحرس الثوري